you mentioned it is work I mean it's
like having a full-time job and then
some what's your day like knowing that
you launched the campaign was it two
days ago or yeah that two or three days
ago so do you have like a set like a
checklist of what you're doing every day
to keep that that drum yeah yeah I mean
there's so much work going on between
the Kickstarter campaign and then the
other fundraising that we're doing for
this project just with the investors and
whatnot they don't have even have time
to create a proper checklist you know
every day every day we come in it's just
kind of a mad scramble to kind of do
what needs to get done we know we need
to update people when you we know we
need to kind of check to see where we're
at with Kickstarter I'm a little
obsessive about and I check maybe every
hour so maybe sometimes more and so you
know the obvious things are you know
making sure we're tweeting it out at
least once or twice a day and not doing
it in an annoying in-your-face kind of
way same with the facebook updates and
you know Facebook and Twitter alone
there's multiple accounts that we're
managing between like the company's
Twitter account and the film's account
so there's a lot of kind of just social
media building graphics that will know
that we know will need either that day
or down the road so yeah just kind of a
roundabout answer saying that we don't
know what we're doing half the time and
just kind of doing as much as we
possibly can to get the word out every
day and what determined the length of
time you're going to choose for the
campaign that's bleeding it's about 31
days so I think it's 31 days uh-huh um
and also the amount 3333 thousand yeah
the we came up with 33,000 as the goal
in part because we had to be realistic
with what we could raise given our
network given our history with
crowdfunding like I just wanted to make
sure we're being realistic and
shooting it because as we all know
Kickstarter is all or nothing and we
don't want to lose you know lose out so
that was one consideration the other
consideration was what will be enough to
get the ball rolling on the film what's
enough to develop the project fully and
what's enough to kind of just start the
production process and 33,000 was kind
of the magic number on the other element
of course is is in factoring on the cost
to produce the perks and the wards and
whatnot for for backers and so yeah
33,000 30,000 was the the magic number
to get the ball rolling on the project
and and what we realistically thought we
could raise and so you decided to not go
with like a 52 day campaign you wanted
it shorter oh just yeah I can't try to
remember why we decided 31 days I mean
we wanted it we wanted to end the
campaign on a Friday like in the evening
because everyone says to end it on a
friday which is often payday for people
and you know you want to give it up time
to people to get home from their jobs
get on their email and exactly do this
damn well yeah that's a one and get
loose and you know um let me get the
wallet exactly yeah so I think I think
it ends on Friday like a 1030pm or
something like that yeah and did you I
mean research on their campaigns to see
what you saw work yeah we researched a
lot of campaigns would probably looked
at about a hundred different campaigns
we watched all the videos or looked at
the rewards the perk structure all the
text on the actual Kickstarter page and
you know a lot of it came down to kind
of what felt good to us and we kind of
went with our gut as far as as as a
viewer as an audience member as a fan
what do we want to read on these pages
and what kinds of perks would get us
excited so along the way we're just
constantly telling ourselves let's put
ourselves in their shoes what do they
want to see what do they need to know
what will excite them
and so that that helped a lot yeah and
what are the worse um the perks for our
kickstarter campaign include some of the
more common things like you know
exclusive updates about the film at the
two-dollar level and then of course a
copy of the DVD a download of the film
but then we came up with some unique
things like Instagram polaroid coasters
because this film is gonna be so
visually driven and hopefully
cinematically kind of beautiful we we
wanted to kind of do something having to
do with photography so yeah one of the
perks is these cool little in suppose
these like polaroid cup coasters you
know postcards and posters a dinner with
myself and the author of a book called
in pursuit of silence which I'm sort of
so what says sort of influence this film
and so things like that yeah yeah sounds
really cool yeah yes that's creative the
dinner with the author like that yeah
thanks and another consideration was
because I experienced this with our last
crowdfunding campaign like it's got to
be rewards that are relatively simple
for us to put together one thing that
was a constant thorn in our side with
the last crowdfunding campaign was this
photo book this elusive photo book that
we promised backers and it seemed like a
really cool idea because we had a
photographer on set on every shoot that
we took in Haiti and so we had these
gorgeous photographs and we thought
coolest you know it's two-foot a book
how hard could it possibly be you know
it was just like it was just so it was
expensive it took just so much time to
design it it was just way more work and
money than we anticipated and it
a pretty big problem for us here in the
office just trying to get that done on
time and ended up being you know several
months late but people were happy when
it finally came and it was that Jess
just Kayla yeah just kayla was our
photographer and she's brilliant we want
to showcase those photos so badly that's
kind of a drove us to want to do this
photo book but we didn't realize how
much work it would be well yeah
beautiful photos are members yeah I'll
to get you guys a copy of the book
pretty guys leave yeah yeah
you